the easiest business to start to make a
million dollar a year is also the
hardest business to get to $100 million
a year and I say this to someone who is
both a product of the education space
which is by the way wink wink the
business model I'm going to talk about
but I've also done 100 million plus in
sales in that business and sold my last
one for 46.2 million and so I have a
very good understanding of being both a
customer in that industry and a supplier
of that industry and so I want to make
this video for two types of people first
is somebody who's like hey I want to
start a business and the second is for
people who have a business and they're
considering switching into an education
or coaching business and this business
and this video is going to talk about
the pros and cons on both sides and the
two biggest considerations that you have
to make one is what's the goal that
you're actually solving for believe it
or not the reason that this thing is
really fast is also the same reason why
it's not going to make you a billionaire
on the second problem or the second
thing that you have to consider is what
problems are going to come up for each
of these businesses and which ones
you're better at solving the problems
that are in this business or the
opportunity in this business and the
problems in this business are the
opportunity in this one and that's why
this thing can be mega mega big takes a
little longer this one can get
moderately big really fast but really
hard to scale from there so let's dive
in coaching information education
digital Course membership businesses are
among the easiest businesses to get to
$100,000 a year $100,000 a month
$200,000 a month but this is what the
business looks like in terms of the
difference between that and a
traditional business a digital course
business looks like this in terms of the
speed a traditional business looks like
this and so the key thing to make this
decision really only comes down to two
factors and they're both incredibly
important but they're very simple to
understand so the first one is what is
your goal if you want to sell a business
and build an asset that you can exit for
25 50 100 $250 million a billion dollar
someday then this business the coaching
digital Etc businesses are not a good
business for that and all we have to do
is look around and see okay of the
people who don't have a brand who
started from scratch and had information
businesses how many of them were able to
get to $10 million per year how many to
$30 million per year how many to $100
million per year the amount of guys at
100 million I can count on one hand and
I know them all and all of them have
deep Brands and have been doing it for
30 plus years almost all of them the
people at $30 million year there's
probably I can count on two hands and I
almost know all of them and think about
how many people are in this space
there's Millions if you count creators
of people in the information digital
product space and so that's a very very
small success rate even at 30 million a
year and so what's interesting is that
there's this massive band of people at
the 500 million2 million $3 million a
year because it is a business that
requires almost no operational
infrastructure to get to that level you
can get get to $2 to $3 million a year
with a team of 10 that for most
entrepreneurs is where they cap out in
terms of their operational skill set
they don't know how to lead they don't
know how to manage so the first thing
you have to figure out is what your goal
is and the second is what problems you
are more comfortable solving all right
let's walk through
this so if your goal is to make let's
say $1 to $3 million per year in a
business this is probably the fastest
and easiest way to get there you have no
inventory you can immediately package
the knowledge and experience that you
have you can deliver very outsized value
to a very Niche audience so for example
gym launch I knew how to run a gym there
is no school for running a gym and so if
you're a gym owner learning from
thousands of other gyms and getting the
best practices off the bat because there
is no book for running a gym no
textbooks right I tried to write one but
there's no there's no real book on it
and so no one tells you how to set up a
membership sale no one tells you what
the script is no one tells you how to
set up your lobby no one tells you what
hours are the ones that are empty and
which ones are full no one tells you how
long to make your sessions no one tells
you how to pay how to pay your trainers
all of these things you have to figure
out on your own and it's and it's so
valuable if you can immediately learn
the stuff and then triple your income
that's incredibly valuable but it's not
sticky once you teach someone they know
it that's why fouryear degrees are four
years not forever you learn it you
graduate and so for that reason they
become very difficult to create Revenue
retention with as in people buy it and
then they leave so that is why this
business is very hard to to turn into an
asset because the recurring nature of it
is very low and on top of that you have
three types of key man risk so if you're
a personal you're an influence you got a
personal brand you're the one who's
bringing the customers you're the one
who's leading the team and you're the
one who's delivering the product if
you're the one who's required to make
the ads then no one's going to buy the
business and say okay well we're just
going to get rid of the guy who makes
all who gets all the customers in well
that's not going to happen let's say you
magically replace yourself on the front
end well you're still the one who's in
charge of making the thing that delivers
all the value which is the product and
the one who's staying on top of it
seeing what's working right now and all
that stuff and if you're not doing that
then they're like okay well maybe we can
replace this but eventually the product
is going to deteriorate and we're going
to be out competed by people who are
newer and better and so okay fine then
you have to replace that these are both
very hard problems to solve and then
finally the entire team's loyal to you
and they started working because they
probably watched your content or
consumed your ads or in some way they
aspire to be like you in some way or
they admire certain traits about you and
so if they're like well if you leave I'm
leaving and so you have this
infrastructure of people who also don't
want to work for anybody else and so
there's huge risk from an asset
perspective to sell or exit this company
and so if you want to make this as
income and just think about this as
getting a really high paying
job then this is a great
opportunity but now I want to talk to
these people so I had three different
business owners and this is why I'm
making this video recently one was a guy
who had a paint paint business who's
doing 4 million bucks a year uh another
was a salon owner doing about 3 or four
million bucks a year uh she had uh six
locations doing lash extend exensions
and other stuff like that and then the
third business was a business was a a
business opportunity like a micro
business where he would set up home
gardens in people's backyards like that
was his that was his thing and people
would pay him to do that and so he could
teach other people how to set up Gardens
in other people's backyards Etc okay so
almost all of these guys were right
here they had enough skill that they
could teach a beginner but not enough
skill to be a master so they could jump
from here and based on the time in the
business they'd be like here like if you
look at this amount of time to here they
would jump all the way to here on their
income they'd jump higher up on that
graph But as time continues to go on
this way this graph as time goes on goes
off the chart and this one is very
difficult to get there especially if you
have a
exit meaning somebody buys your business
because you built an asset that does not
rely on you when you have 60 locations
and you're not the one in the ads and
you're not the one delivering the Lash
extensions that's a very sellable
business and what I can also promise you
is that to get from 1 to
five going from 55 to 60 locations
you're going to make more money at 55 to
60 and it's going to cost you almost no
time but most people quit right when
they reach a boss that they don't know
how to beat and what's interesting about
this is that the cap on this business
and the cap for most people in local in
Lo in Chains or traditional service
businesses is about the same it's
because they don't know how to get the
next level of leadership in and so
they're able to get the first team in
maybe one manager but they can't get the
next level of leadership in that's what
takes you from five locations to 25 to
30 locations that's going from one city
where you've got three to five to five
cities we have three to five if you're
thinking locations but you can think
about this as an accounting firm it
doesn't really matter but fundamentally
you have another layer of leadership
which is why people get stuck and so if
you are in this business then you just
need to realize that you're about to get
the best returns that come at the end
and not get the shiny object now if you
are in this boat and you deceive
yourself and you say you know what I
love making an impact I love helping
people with their businesses more than I
like I like paint pain help I like
helping paint owners make more money
with their paint business than I do like
helping homeowners paint their houses
fine but guess what that will one wear
off when I was in the gym business in
the beginning I was like I love Fitness
but guess what it very quickly became
not about Fitness it became about
business and so once I got my H 100th
and 500th and thousandth weight loss
testimonial and before and after I
stopped caring it's just like I I got
numb to it because I had so many
testimonials just like yeah you know you
you you ate less and you did resistance
training and you got stronger and you
built muscle and like yeah like your
body changes that's kind of the point
and the thing is is that right now this
is novel it's new now you're like oh wow
I you know this guy was able to move
houses and go into a new zip code and
his kid went to a new school and he's
got time for his family and as crazy as
what I'm about to say will sound you
will get used to it too it'll be the
same as the other thing because you're
going to say well I mean dude it's not
you'll start downplaying you're like
listen man I mean you ran some ads that
you that we already knew worked and you
ran an offer that was better and you set
up a sales process which you didn't have
and you had a script which you also
didn't have when you run that thing
you're going to make more money and so
it it's it starts the The razzled Dazzle
around it starts to go away it's just
exciting because it's new and so my
first big piece for either of these
people is do not straddle their line
you've got one ass that's an ass okay
you can't ride two
horses pick and it's the fundamental
skill of entrepreneurs being able to
make a decision and if you can't make a
decision and you can't commit and
acquisitions.com we Define commitment by
eliminating Alternatives when you get
married you eliminate all other women or
all other men that you're going to be
dating that's how you commit you say I
will eliminate all Alternatives and so
if you want to commit to either of these
things it means you need to eliminate
the Alternatives focus is the measure of
the amount of things that you say no to
so somebody who says no to more things
is more focused than somebody who says
yes to more stuff
period so if we're looking at these two
opportunities this if you want to be in
this range then great then this is a
good opportunity but understand that
this will cap and it will get very
difficult to scale which goes to problem
number
two so I'll write the goal here real
quick if you want to have a $10 million
plus
exit then sticking with the traditional
business is the better model now real
talk
over 5
years you might make that an
income over here and not be able to exit
the business but you'll have made that
an income and so there are lifestyle
benefits so here you'll make more income
faster and you'll sustain a higher
you'll be able to sustain a higher
Lifestyle the whole ride and so that's
also a little bit of a trade-off so here
you usually have to reinvest more of
that cash into opening new locations
into hiring better people whatever less
so than you do in a digital products or
education business so that's a pro or
con depending how you want see it now
the second element of this is what
problem are you more comfortable solving
so if you're in this business you're
going to have huge key man risk which is
you have to figure out how to transfer
everything that makes you special to
other people without making them so
special that they leave your business
and take your customers very very
hard on top of that you're going to be
in the
talent and
training business and if you really
really want to
scale then you have to build a
brand because acquisition will only
become more and more expensive as you
get to colder and colder audiences which
means you need to build positive brand
associations with you over time which
means the product needs to consistently
be very very good so you get good
reviews good word of mouth and that
continues to compound in time rather
than compound against you which is what
happens for most people because they
make medial products because they only
are a little bit better than most people
not way better than most people so the
problem that you have in this business
on the other side of sticking with the
thing that you're in if you're in a
let's say you're the painting business
you're the accounting business you're
the whatever business the problem that
you have to deal with is that it's
slower in the beginning this is faster
in the beginning slower near the end
this is slower in the beginning faster
near the end so number one it's slower
number
two it typically has more Capital
involved you have to reinvest more of
the money to continue to grow it
especially if you have brick and mortar
locations you literally have to spend
money to open a new location to expand
capacity here there is no Capital
expense to to sell more people into your
membership sell more people into your
course not really you just have more
people you have to hire but that's it so
in this business it takes longer and it
costs more money but because it takes
longer and it costs more money there are
fewer people who do it successfully and
as a result they create something that
we can put here in big letters which is
you create an asset you create something
that someone some else could own and so
what I will say here is that if you
stick with it from here to here and you
get good enough that you really
understand all the Special Sauce about
the
business you might not ever want to tell
anybody about it because you want to own
the whole thing and I'll say like ad
acquisition. comom the last chain we
recently purchased it was a franchise
and it had more franchise locations open
than it had corporate and I bought all
of the franchises out and so we took all
30 plus locations in house and made them
all corporate and we did that because I
looked at the economics and I was like
wait a second why would we want to make
8% when the amount of work that it takes
to open a franchise location is 50% of
the work that it takes to open a
location we own the whole thing on
anyways and with franchisees and
customers by the way you can't fire
them with because they paid you if you
have employees and you have a bad
manager you swap them out and so we have
more control and we can know that
they're going to execute correctly the
amount of franchise or buddies I have I
can't even count and they all say the
same thing man these franchisees are
idiots they all think they're smarter
than me they all want to do it their own
way right and their own way is the wrong
way and so they end up making less money
and they don't do it right and so then
all of a sudden your reputation tanks
because they're not following your
process and it's a whole cycle and so
there's a reason Panda Express is a
significantly more valuable company is
that Mr Panda owns them all he owns all
the net income from every single
location and he owns the dirt and he
owns the property itself all 2600 did
almost 4 billion in sales with 27% net
margins absurd 27 net margins it's
almost a billion a year in income income
cash flow
woo but he didn't start coaching other
Chinese restaurant owners when he had
five locations he just stuck with it and
so it goes back to what goal do you have
if you want to build an asset that
eventually will require less of you less
work and give you ultimate Freedom this
business model will do it if you're
looking to make a 100 500 a million
bucks two million bucks a year and are
willing to continue to work and
basically always have to keep working in
order to do that then this is a good
business model reiterating this if
you're here right which is at this early
part here then this model is the faster
and easier way to make a million $2
million dolls a year it
is if you want this and you're further
along in this curve then for most of you
it would make sense to just stick with
what you're doing because you're about
to unlock this huge amount of value
that's going to get created and so I
want to give you an even-handed approach
to thinking about this and understanding
that you also may be let's say you're at
this point and your goals might actually
change and so when I was starting out if
someone's like hey you can make a
million bucks a year I'd be like screw
asset value I don't care about exits I
was like I just want to make money in
which case great vehicle but what
happens and the reason that you can look
at Alex Becker who I think got up to $25
or $30 million a year in his information
business switched to hyos and then built
a multi million doll Enterprise with
software Sam ovens had consulting.com
they were doing 30 plus million doll a
year and then from all the skills he
learned transferred to school.com and
then made it significantly more
valueable Enterprise right now mind you
School makes less cash flow than
consulting.com
because this business requires more
capital and is slower at the onset
school's in year five or six right now
right but it's scaling like this now
because it's easier to add 5,000
customers in a month in this business
and almost impossible to do it here
especially if you have Service attached
to it and so there are pros and cons on
both sides and you have to realize that
your goal will change and if you do get
to this point where you're right at this
point where you're like well shoot
because sometimes people go the other
way they say hey I've been doing this
for 5 years I want to start a software
company look at all the people who are
successful with software companies who
made the switch let me tell you the one
Comon trait because I know all of them
they stopped
this and they started doing
that and so in either
direction if you're going to do it do it
and don't do the other one so I want to
talk to Avatar number three hidden bonus
is somebody who's been successful here
for 5 years or someone who's been
moderately successful here for 5 years
the other side looks really tempting
because if you're over here you've got
enough cash saved up you've been making
a million bucks 2 million bucks a year
for a while and you're like man now I
want to have that 10 20 50 $100 million
plus exit right I get it I was there on
the other hand if you're here you're
like man I've been I've been putting
five plus years in this thing I want to
start making some money I want to start
making some cash flow and so this starts
looking attractive and I'll give you the
quote from my CFO there's in every
business and so the key here is let me
walk you through the transition on
either side if you're going from
traditional business over to digital
education
business what you don't want to do is
keep the traditional business and so
there's the fallacy of like well one
some of you want to keep it because
you're afraid of actually making the
jump and this is actually what makes you
money in which case
just keep doing what you're doing but if
you really are going to make the jump
then there's this idea that you want to
have keep a test kitchen and I actually
think it's not true so let me explain so
the concept of a test kitchen is works
when you're making food because you want
to standardizing process and you roll
out the food making process across all
locations it's much easier to roll it
out you have franchise control or you
have corporate control whatever now if
you're in an education business you
teaching your employees on site how to
do do a new process or do a new play is
not how you're going to teach all the
people in your community all the people
who are your customers that buy your
stuff from you from an education
perspective what are you actually going
to do you're going to probably record
some videos and add some sort of Zoom
call you know add-on to help give
support maybe some Community Support as
well but that's about it and so if you
want to test whether or not a new play
is going to work in this education model
then test it like you would actually
roll it out which is if you have 100
customers take 10 customers that
represent different segments of the
market both geographically like what
Market are they in and what skill level
they're at and so when we ran things at
gym launch I wouldn't say let me take
the top 10 gyms and test something out
because that's going to give me bad data
I'm going to have the top 10 winners
they're going to make everything work
but if I take the bottom 10 on
everything nothing's going to work but
if something does work for them it's
going to definitely work for everyone
and so what I did was I took two people
from each of the 20% bands so two people
from the top top 20% % two from the next
20 next 20 in the middle next 20 the
bottom middle and then next 20 at the
very bottom so I had 10 people in
different markets at different skill
levels and so when I rolled it out I got
to have a representative sample of both
markets and performance to see whether
this play actually worked and I see that
as a far superior model to actually
creating better products and better
education that also doesn't require you
to keep an appendage of a business that
you have to stay attached to because
whether you like it or not if there's a
problem in this business and you know a
a client sleeps with a uh an employee
right or an employee stealing guess
what's taking your shower time I don't
care if this is 10% of your income it's
going to take 50% or 100% of your mental
bandwidth until the problem goes away
your brain is going to deal with what's
urgent not necessarily what's important
and so this is why Focus is so important
so if you're going to switch from here
to here cut it sell it don't have any
appendages and go all in on this if you
are going to go from the education
business over to a more traditional
business like software or service
business that you want to attach to it
then guess what you cut this business
you say I'm done with that and I'm going
to build this for real just don't
straddle the line I've yet to see anyone
succeed big doing this and the vast
majority of people do exactly that which
is why I'm making the video so you have
your three scenarios you're starting out
you just want to make income then yes
digital products education businesses is
probably the fastest and easiest way to
make a lot of money pretty quickly if
you want to build an asset that's going
to be valuable and sellable without you
and you're comfortable with a slower
pace of growth and putting more capital
in this is something that's going to
give you a 1050 $100 million plus exit
if you're going to make the transition
then pick if you are in this bucket and
you're like that is cool I don't
necessarily want that right now that's
not the stage of the journey I'm at we
have a free thing that you can do at
school.com
games where I will lead you through
starting your business right now 50
54.1% of of people who start the school
games with the paid Community make their
first dollar online very very proud of
that if you are this business and you're
trying to get to here you want to have a
massive exit then acquisition. comom
every once in a while we run workshops
at our headquarters we help businesses
that are smaller than our portfolio size
kind of take the next step so that
hopefully someday maybe we're the ones
who buy it from you and help you scale
it from 30 locations to 300 that being
said this is the path I want to make it
clear for you give you the pros and the
cons on either side and hopefully get
you to commit one way or the other